and we're live
so today we have a special guest with us
a good friend bernard carrick the former
commissioner of nypd you know in new
york they had the five banana you know
the five mob families they had the
banana the colombo
uh all these other families they had but
it was also the carrick family because
you have to be just as tough as them
to be able to hang being the 40th
commissioner and
also correctional right you were you
were also the commissioner of uh
the the jail system in new york which
was pretty epic i ran
rikers in the new york city jail system
and back in my day
uh we we had about 133
000 admissions a year my daily
population was about 22
500. when we took over the system
uh we averaged about 150
stabbings and slashings per month
when i left and became police
commissioner in 2000
we had knocked down the inmate on inmate
violence by about 93 percent
93 and that is why we have
bernard carrick here today to talk about
what's going on and how he would go
about fixing it we'd like to kind of get
some insight on that but outside of that
uh we just got back from uh dallas yeah
in dallas we
had a great event with 2 500 some people
there we rented out the cowboys stadium
we had bo jackson there dylan and bo
jackson had a moment together
um conversations after what was your
favorite part
beau tell me what your favorite part
that you you know with beau or just the
whole cowboys experience i mean what an
event are you freaking kidding me
so my i i i will tell you the the one
part that stands out to me because we
got in on sunday you spoke all day
sunday
to to your mds right your marketing
director so those maybe
300 people in the room right so that's
keep in mind we haven't
had a major event like uh anytime like
this since
2019 right i mean so this is my first
php event we just had our first big
valuetainment event
uh a month ago not even 100 people in a
room in the breakers so
to get 100 people in a room these days
that's pretty impressive point is we got
300 people in a room
think it's a pretty big deal all right
pat speaks it's awesome it's awesome
monday morning rolls around
you know i tend to run maybe a little
bit late sometimes don't be never
whatever
you're like a 5 a.m whatever so this
particular day i think the meeting
started at 9 i strolled in at 9 30 i had
some stuff to do
in the morning i walk in burn and
the room is packed 2500 people
i did not expect that it was insane to
the point where
i'm expecting showed up no nobody showed
up
no no nobody i'm saying oh yeah fire
department showed up behind closed doors
because we had standing room only
we had to bring new chairs and we had to
get some guys to get out yeah
it was problematic behind closed doors i
did not even know that it looked like it
went off
directly the hotel showed up we were
having conversations but anyways it was
a great event
yeah afterwards we go we uh uh shut down
the cowboy stage shut down cowboy
stadium yeah and it's this is right up
to canola's fight by the way this is uh
had to fight out uh 76 000 some people
want to watch this guy fight and the guy
broke the other guy's
jaw did you see that yeah i did he broke
his face pretty much with a punch
bernie please don't get any ideas all
right now i'm a good guy he's a friend
again so question
a huge event feels feels great to get
back on the scene you rent out dally's
cowboy brick and stadium what
how does it feel you're the ceo you're
given the opening and closing messages
how does it feel
to do a major event like that this is
this is our second one at the cowboys
stadium so
they're very easy to deal with great
people phenomenal experience and this
time around we brought bo
yeah bo is pissed off he misses two
flights because of uh the lightning and
the you know
they're saying canceled canceled
cancelled he's the kind of guy he's old
school he wants to be on time so he gets
in
ticked off at mother nature this
[ __ ] you know i cannot believe
this he is pissed off we're looking to
fight mother nature and possibly
you can win possibly he'll win and then
anyways he gets up there and matt
sappala does a phenomenal job interview
shout out to this great
great conversations great questions
shout out to t rude and morale for
making that whole thing
[Music]
for a straight hour he didn't have to do
that i was like boy you can go home he's
like nah man i'm good i'm having fun
so he was in his element you know he was
in his element then afterwards we went
and sat down
had conversations telling stories with
dylan
and adam showed a video to dylan that's
been on dylan's mind
all weekend long it's the
why don't you tell them what the video
is all right are you a big welfare fan
anyway will ferrell's in this movie east
by the show eastbound and down and he
plays his character and it's basically
imagine that i'm trying to make the two
of you laugh
okay and whoever laughs first loses so
he gets into this ric
flair-esque character and the story is
i'm making love to my wife
donna i come home one night yeah exactly
close the window yeah ac82
follow me i'm on top of donna she don't
like it at all
she's sweating my son gabriel walks in
82 i don't know i'd imagine yeah
he said what's up oh no son go
let him what do you say she gabriel
walks in she
my wife donna yells gabriel get out of
here you know
let the boy watch
like i had to learn from my father
before me
and his father at this point these guys
can't even control themselves yeah
anyway so dylan watched this video all
weekend long all he's been saying
we're sitting there talking about
jackson bo has no clue what's going on
i asked i suppose we're the greatest
athletes of all time so both says i'm
gonna have to put jim brown there i'm
gonna put michael jordan he gave all
these names
and then dylan says how about frank how
about jackie robinson
says you know what we have to put jackie
there's but he says you forgot kobe
bryant
yeah we have to go how about jesse owens
is and then all of a sudden i don't know
we're dylan every we're having a serious
conversation dylan says
bo let the boy watch
dylan has no clue what he's talking
about
that your son is asking you to let the
boy watch
the irony and the fact that your father
is named gabriel is just the most ironic
part there's too many things there that
makes
um so uh bernie
you're a giants fan you're a jets guy i
mean let's bring this back to you you're
from new york you ran new york
for a freaking decade you know i'm i'm
not a big football
fan uh you know i i like the giants
because they're in new york
um you know i like the yankees uh
i used to go to i usually attended a
bunch of games i don't uh
i don't go anymore i'm not not happy
with the nfl and some of these other
teams that have
supported black lives matter and all
this nonsense
um so i've kind of stayed away from it
gotcha
so not not a bo jackson fan maybe or
what well jackson yeah
i like him good man good guy okay
now but you were a football fan before
like you were a guy that followed
i would follow it yeah so you went from
following now you're not following it
no in the last three years the last two
strangers so you're that fan who says i
was a fan now i'm not
no so so is it fair to say if i go to
red count today at five o'clock
hypothetically and you're there kai
greene is there
aaron is there you guys are working out
i'm probably not going to see you in a
kaepernick jersey is that is that a
first session that's pretty fair to say
that's pretty fair so what did you do
you will not
see me working out with kai greene and
aaron yeah i'll be by myself by yourself
those boys are on their own yeah they're
they're off to this i mean first of all
kai just
kai looks like uh aaron's a big guy
aaron aaron's a big guy
but kai is a a monster
yeah so i i gotta tell you he went to uh
i took him to cpac with me
right the conservative political action
uh committee uh event and um
he wanted to go he wanted to go to see
kai green kai greene
which i don't know for me it was
surprising this is a brooklyn dude
wants to go to cpac i said all right so
aaron and i
and aaron's wife and uh and kai we go to
cpac
and uh you know i know a bunch of these
guys that you know former
universe former olympians but i've never
hung with them like
at dinner at lunch so we go in this
we go in this restaurant and we sit down
to have lunch
and aaron's wife orders like a sandwich
and aaron orders a cheeseburger and i
order a cheeseburger
and kai he says okay i'll take a uh
a cheeseburger and um with um
you know uh those red fries
and and a chicken sandwich too and um
and in a big salad and um
in that in that in the in another
sandwich
this is kai this is kai and the ladies
the ladies looking at him and she goes
oh
is do we need another c is somebody else
coming
and he goes uh no that's for me it's for
me i do 12 lunches well let me see how
much he weighs
off season this guy is 310 pounds how
tall
he's five eight five yeah i was gonna
say he's he's about five eight
have you seen what he looks like kai's
physique let's pull him up can you can
so he's he sits there and he has this
you know this lunch for five on his own
he sits there
much for five for one yeah look yeah
he's a small
guy he's got the beautiful rat tail he's
a small dude
and so so we get done we get done with
that lunch
yeah and we go on to the vip room in in
the
in the cpac center and about an hour
later
we're in that room and he's like tooling
around the room and he's looking in the
little
you know they have the hors d'oeuvre
things and i said to aaron i said what's
he looking for
he said he's hungry i see he's hungry
yeah he just got enough [ __ ] food for
about
30 people yeah that's he's hungry that's
sensible
again let the boy eat let the boy eat
that's him but
but they they do you know they have six
eight meals a day to maintain that
physique and weight you need it
well you're considering doing something
like that you said no no no no no i'm
not
not working out like that no no but
eating more small meals
this is not they're not eating sick
small meals these guys are eating six
cows a day
is what he's telling
you can eat you know and i went through
this in my
turmoil i learned how to eat
six eight times a day but it was super
small meals
um you know and and you know they have
everybody has these diets right they
have 100 different diets
here's the diet the real diet protein
vegetables and fruit i don't know what
the hell you call that
you know they got names diet yeah paleo
and all these other
caveman it's all bs protein
vegetables and fruit if you do that you
do it in small portions
six to eight times a day you will knock
off the weight
you'll be in phenomenal shape and uh you
know that's that's kind of what uh
what i would do that's not kai's denied
kai is trying to maintain three ten
three hundred pounds this guy's eight
this guy's eaten think about it i mean
he's eating
4 000 calories per meal per meal
yeah your time six meals but he spends
he spends eight hours a day in the gym
foreign he took a different route he
went from
doing the bodybuilding side to now he no
longer competes he is more doing movies
hollywood he took a different route
and have you have you ever met him no i
got it you got to get him on the show
i'm telling you
smart guy you know just soft spot strong
opinions or no
pretty strong opinions um but he's
he's a soft-spoken guy not the nicest
man you could meet his biggest opponent
was who phil heath him and phil went at
it back and forth
uh you know all those top guys you know
cutler
cutler you know those kind of guys yeah
you're a good you're a good friend with
phil heath
very good friends with phil heath yeah
and so they went they went the same era
and i think kai would go
second many times and kai
a couple times almost could have picked
it up a lot of people who are kai fans
would say
you know he could have had one or two
the guy had a very nice physique very
very you know what when you're at that
level when you're at that level
you know it's symmetric it's it's uh you
know it's
it's a muscle off the bottom line is all
those guys
all those guys whether it's cutler or
coleman or you know
all of them they're phenomenal athletes
oh i mean
first of all you're talking about it's
the most
judgmental sport in the world it's you
against the judges
in your little panties okay literally
you're wearing panties
okay and you're sitting there posing and
they're saying
his ass if kai green comes and sits here
don't talk about panties
he does he eats a lot anyway so let's
let's get into we got a lot of stories
to cover i'm going to cover some of the
stories here and we'll get into it one
is gas prices
which is insane we may even go into that
on what happened with gas prices with
this
you know dark web uh hackers that came
out they got
actually an interesting story on what
they're doing i think it's important to
see the connection there with russia uh
u.s
job opening hits record high in march uh
we have a number of states that have
ended boosting their unemployment
benefits amid hiring concerns
uh another article we got about
applebee's aiming to hire 10 000 workers
in may
with an interview incentive which is
pretty big deal to see applebee's
wanting to hire ten thousand
amazing incentive program but that's
what's great is the fact that they're
hiring
ten thousand it's telling you the future
looks bright so anytime you see an
applebee's hiring 10 000 they're trying
to say
things are about to go back to normal
which is great to hear something like
that okay so
inflation skyrocket and record-breaking
i think april uh that we had the
last time we went up this 4.2 was what
in 08
when they had a spike like this uh
analytics suggests
96 of users leave ab tracking disabled
and ios 14.5 this is hurting facebook
tremendously because they're allowing
people to say do you want them to have
your information
and 96 are saying no i don't want them
to track what i'm doing
toyota's q4 profits nearly doubled
beating expectations softbank just
shocked his critics by landing the
biggest profit
in the history of a japanese company
judge dismisses nra bankruptcy case
colonial pipeline attack tip of an
infrastructure risk iceberg
dhs cyber chief says gas stations in the
southeast run out of gas as people panic
buying fuel new york city violent
crime is up so is the city's police
budget which obviously we'll talk to you
about that new york city appears
prepares for return to government for
government workers why new york city's
homelessness rates
skyrocketed for adults but dropped for
families during the pandemic
california governor newsom is proposing
a 12 billion dollar
budget to house state homelessness
l.a murder rate continues to climb
murder in los angeles nearly doubles up
nearly 200 percent violent crimes rising
at rapid pace
sheriff's statistics show saint louis uh
sheriff's statistics show
then uh something happened this weekend
with republicans ousting uh
liz cheney from leadership over her i
say this weekend it was a couple days
ago
we haven't done a podcast for a while
over opposition to trump and gop
election lines which i'm kind of curious
to know what you're going to say about
that
and then we have to talk about palestine
and israel kai is that story here or no
is that story here which page is it on
well yeah let me see if we have okay
sydney hamas commander killed
as israel strikes gaza palestinians
fire rockets first story i want to get
into is actually
gas prices so if you want to go to page
five
colonial pipeline attack and we're going
to page six
to talk about these gas prices what
happened to it why the lines are so long
and why everyone's panicking so
colonial pipeline attack tip of
infrastructure risk iceberg dhs
cyber um is this is this the gas story
or no
darks it is okay colonial pipeline
attack tip of the infrastructure rise
risk iceberg dhs cyber chief fox
business story after a hacking group
forced colonial pipeline the nation's
largest system for refined oil products
to shut down suddenly government
officials are warning cyber attacks
against u.s businesses and
infrastructure
will become more frequent acting cyber
security infrastructure security agency
director
brandon wells made that clear during q a
while testifying before lawmakers on the
senate homeland
security committee if there is ransom uh
ransomware focused on colonial there is
likely to be ransomware
focus on other critical infrastructure
as well isn't that true
as senator rob portman republican ohio
the ranking member of the committee
and wells responded that is true the
attack on the colonial pipeline said to
be
the work of russian ransomware group
darkseid
is training supply and panic and drivers
who have lined up at gas stations
up and down the east coast with north
carolina virginia declaring a state of
emergency
and then obviously this has caused the
gas stations and southeast to run out of
gas as
people panic buying fuel gas stations in
south southern eastern united states
face significant
outages wednesday this makes it in this
stretches into the sixth day as of 7 am
eastern standard time 24.8 percent of
all gas stations in north carolina 15.4
percent of all gas stations in georgia
15 in virginia are without gasoline let
me say that one more time
a quarter of all gas stations in
carolina that's the third largest
economy in america
according to uh the city is you know
it's it's
it's a big number right then when you're
looking at that according to gas buddy
as an ab track fuel demand
the supply chain appears to be much
worse in metropolitan cities
gas body reported outages impacting 71
percent of stations in metro charlotte
nearly 60 percent in atlanta 72 percent
in raleigh 73
in pensacola anyways i can give you a
bunch of stats what are your thoughts on
what's going on with this
well you want to start with this no go
ahead okay well
there's two different stories here
there's the actual cyber attack
on colonial pipeline um i think it's
important to point out that uh
sort of a big miami
journalist type guy made a major
announcement he's like people in south
florida don't worry about this
we do not get our gas from colonial
pipeline we actually get shipments
from the ports so this is not affecting
south florida so
for local people we're like all right
cool but
there's i guess two stories going on
here number one um
the cyber warfare i mean you could
probably speak about
warfare way better than i but warfare is
now turning cyber
and this is a major concern i think it
was ted koppel
um that that i spoke with a few years
ago
at a big nalba event and and it was kind
of
2016 when trump was talking about the
wall and all that and it was hoopla on
hoopla and goes look
the biggest issue we should have we
should all be thinking about is
uh cyber warfare and obviously after
covid
you know whatever you would call uh
pandemic warfare
but also the electrical grid like
imagine if they can take out the
electrical grid that'd be absurd
so but the good news is this has been
rectified
everything is kind of getting back to
normal and then back to that's sort of a
macro level then from a
micro perspective kai if you want to
pull up the picture that i just sent you
this reminds me it's to use the metaphor
from the
from kovid people freaking out buying
toilet paper i got to get toilet paper
i'm a hoarding toilet paper
it's ridiculous i need the toilet paper
and it's like why did we all need all
that toilet paper during coven
i didn't i had covet i didn't wasn't
going to the bathroom more than
usual so here's an example that i saw
online this couple is filling up
a suv full of gas
this is classic with the kids probably
sitting in the back yeah they're
smelling all of that you know the guy's
300 pounds you should probably just take
a walk for a second
but rather than driving the suv that's
just that's just me i got personal i'm
sorry buddy i take that back
the wives calves look like bo jackson's
that's just me again legit
but legit but this is what's going on
this is
people overreact they rush to judgment
listen all night last night
if you ride up and down the highway
you'll see lines you would have seen
lines all night last night
they don't really have a problem here
but people panic
just like the toilet paper and i don't i
i really never figured out what the
toilet paper had to do with the covet
stuff
like toilet paper i don't know uh
nobody got diarrhea from covet no that
was not a symptom no
it was not as simple i still can't smell
six months later but i've been able to
bathrooms is pretty normal not a bad
problem yeah yeah so uh
you know the toilet paper uh was an
issue just like the gas
people panic they panic and it's usually
out of ignorance
um the problem we have you know at all
the things that you mentioned
you know the grid issues the electro
electrical grid
the water basins you know are they
uh are they problematic could they be
yeah they could be
but the bottom line is cyber
is probably one of the deadliest threats
we face today
as a national security risk because you
have
russia you have china you have el
salvador
iran north korea north korea
these are all you know they all have
their elements out there
that are trying to attack the us
without doing it publicly and how do you
do that you get into the banking systems
you get into systems like this
they could do a lot of damage a lot of
damage
and that's what we have to worry about
and and here's what's interesting
can you pull up that tweet that i sent
you this is this is pretty insane to be
thinking about how ridiculous this is
getting
here's u.s consumer product safety
commission
do not fill plastic bags with gasoline
yeah plastic bags
plastic bags with gasoline what do you
mean plant do you even have to tweet
about the fact that the only reason
they're tweeting that is why
because someone's dude maybe they think
it's a water bag or something hey let me
go fill up plastic how do you even
fill up plastic this is this one this is
what irrational actors are thinking
about
when they hear that there's a gas
shortage and they don't own one of the
big red buckets because homeboy over
there just bought
ten thousand when put them in his truck
and now your only option is i got to go
fill up a garbage bag versus gasoline
and you're freaking out like you said
they're uninformed and they're just
acting
so so here's what we want this is the
largest u.s pipeline
number one largest u.s fuel pipeline
okay
dark dark side hackers took a hundred
gigabyte of data
they stole okay they have a uh a double
extortion scheme
there's a ransom they want here in
return if you go look up who dark side
hackers are
they operate on the dark web it's not
political they flat out tell you we are
not political we don't lean on the left
or the right or anywhere
we simply just want money on their
website they tell you which companies
they've attacked which companies they've
hacked what they've gotten
on their website clearly and they say
they have a very value-based principle
they don't go after funeral homes they
don't go after insurance company they
don't go after
companies that take care of a elderly
they're they're such
oh what nice principle
thieves principles principle-based
hackers and uh biden came out and said
look this has nothing to do with
uh russia meaning the government it has
something to do with
the the the people that are hacking are
from russia but we don't know if they're
linked to russia or not obviously gas
price is one of the highest
in seven years but if you really think
about it here's what you got to be
thinking about
so go and think about what kova did to
us for 12 months
how much did kobe cost us i was talking
to noam chomsky
and he said such an interesting thing he
said look what
osama bin laden did to u.s he said osama
bin laden during bush and obama
he got the u.s government his goal was
to make u.s government go bankrupt
chasing this guy
u.s spent 3.6 trillion dollars just to
catch this guy
he says what human being in the world
has
ever been worth 3.6 trillion dollars
the most expensive human being ever in
the world
was osama bin laden think about that the
most expensive human being in the world
was osama bin laden that's how much you
have spent
to go capture the discussion right 3.6
trillion dollars so now
you come back and look at something like
this how much should covet cost u.s
how much 5 trillion sold so far
in excess of five in excess of 5.6 okay
five to six trillion dollars forget
about the printing money all this stuff
five to six trillion dollars right and
now things are coming back that uh
you know fauci was part of a funded
project i don't know if you saw that or
not that they
helped out with china years ago and now
they're kind of wanting to remove their
names but on the bottom of it this lady
who did
this a report on the bottom she says
that this research was funded by i think
it's nih which
fauchi's name is on that now faction's
coming back and saying we have nothing
to do with this
and they're saying how reckless this
could have been because a virus could
have come out et cetera et cetera
what does this have to do with covert
and fauci here's what it has to do with
it
the threats you know you know how they
say what is that one line you know
if wars were fought in you know
the next world war iii will be fought
with what sticks and bones you know
sticks and uh with words
no no no no sticks and stones meaning
it's going to be the end of the world
they're going to i don't think that's
going to be the case
if you actually think about what the
next wars are going to be the toughest
things about the next war is you don't
know who's doing it
there is no fingerprints today it's
tough to find the fingerprints today how
do you go back and see who's behind this
thing here how do you not know these
were
operate you know people who are working
on the inside with the russian
government that are doing this how do
you not know that this is funded you
don't know that stuff the paper trail
to find a lot of stuff is tough today
you don't know but why because it's done
online
the the hackers they can find ways to
eliminate their ips so you don't know
where it's coming from and
these guys are becoming so good at what
they're doing today you know it it
uh this reminds me of the cali cartel
back in the
80s 90s right for everything
that pablo escobar and those guys are
those guys for every element that we put
together to
attack them to go after their networks
to
you know kill their their you know
groups everything we did you know what
and so think of it like this you can't
wiretap a cell phone
right this is back in the 80s coming out
of the 80s going into the 90s we figured
out how to get up on the phones
so they went to pagers then we figured
out how to get
on the pagers they take one step
we have to follow it up with two or
three to catch up how long does that
take to catch up by the way
it depends on what it is but it takes a
while okay it's not immediate
you know they're thinking the criminal
element is this
they're constantly thinking of ways to
circumvent
the law circumvent law enforcement and
every time they do that
we have to come up with a way to combat
it in this
this stuff is like star wars
realistically and today
um you know there are kids out there
15 year old kids that are in
high schools that in in my town for
example
in bergen county new jersey there are
kids in high schools
that you know get visits from the fbi
and the secret service because they just
happened to tap into
you know michelle obama's banking just
for shits and giggles but
just to tell them just to play
they're playing a game yeah they're
playing a game but that's the
intelligence level of some of these kids
today
and what happens then they go into the
private sectors they go into government
sectors
they go into criminal sectors um and
they go out there and do this stuff
so that the genius of our younger
generation
when it comes to this is incredible um
and it's frightening who's more creative
who's more creative
uh cia fbi uh
you know dea or criminals who is more
creative
um the criminals are more creative
because they're there first
they get there first right so they have
to be creative they already know what we
have the ability to do
yeah so they have to get creative to
circumvent that
but i will i will tell you this when the
fbi has a problem or the cia has a
problem they can't really figure it out
who do they go to boom they go to the
criminals right
they get their informants they get their
sources
um they bring in people that can get the
job done
and and sometimes it's it's like in the
classic movie catch me as you can frank
now let me see the guys all right we
can't figure this guy out let's bring
him in get him right let's go get him
and now he's in a
and now he's like one of the more
outspoken people out there talking about
money laundering and washing money and
not using that
credit card roosevelt went to uh joseph
kennedy you know because he's like
listen man the way you can manipulate
the stock market i have to find out what
you're doing to
find the next criminals yeah right and
that's how the whole sec got started
back in the days they have to find out
how would you manipulate the market
today how would you mess with the market
today
but these hackers they're not driven by
the same things that others are driven
by they're not driven by
money they're not driven they're driven
by you know so
some are driven by money some it's not
all of them though but not all of them
yeah some of them are driven by
revenge they're driven by you said what
did you say watch what i'm gonna do or
it's a game you don't think i can do
this it's okay
exactly it's it's a game it's political
it's revenge it's you know it's
financial at least these dark side guys
whoever these guys are there's flat out
saying
look man we're just great at what we do
we want money that's all we care about
you give us at least there being a
fully full disclosure we want a very
one-dimensional relationship we're very
good at what we do we're going to make
your life a living kill just give us the
money we'll leave you alone
so literally it's crazy what these young
kids could do i think it was like a 15
year old kid that
hacked into twitter or something like
that and started tweeting under jack
dorsey or whatever the ridiculous story
was like that
you know what's scary is you look at
some of the dark side hackers
who are they hacking they're hacking
police departments
they're hacking police departments
they're hacking government agencies
they're going to police departments and
saying what's their outcome
money money they want paid
you know we're gonna you know we're
gonna shut down your city's ability
to you know to get uh payments
for city electric you know utilities
we're gonna shut that down uh you know
we want a hundred thousand dollars in
bitcoin
and we want it by 12 p.m today and if
you don't do it
we're shutting that ability down so they
look at it like this the city looks at
it like this one
we're not going to grab them we're not
going to catch them we may catch them
later on down the line but we ain't
getting them no time
soon to stop this and two
if they shut our ability down to collect
utility payments from
city residents it's going gonna cost us
five million dollars over the next two
weeks three weeks a month
give them the hundred thousand and so
they'll negotiate with terrorists and
pay them that's what you're saying
cyber terrorist cities pay cities are
paid
yeah tells you to power these guys by by
the way that's the next phase
so so a couple years ago
i'm at an insurance conference i don't
know palm springs i'm at an insurance
conference
ceo gets up okay and they said just want
you to know
hackers right now are hacking into life
insurance policies
and they're taking cash values out of
life insurance policies
wow yes so the ceo
we had a six hour session two hours of
it was just about cyber security okay
so we went and investigated to find out
what we need to be doing with cyber
security i mean you can go out and get
the best cyber security insurance you
can get the guys to come in no matter
how much guys you get
there's going to be people that know how
to go around it you're just trying to
protect yourself exactly what i said
yeah
you're simply trying so today one of the
biggest sellers today
is cyber security insurance it's not
even about
hiring the best engineer to fight off
cyber security
hackers it's to get a cyber security
insurance you get a five million dollar
policy
who would have thought the cyber
security insurance business would have
been this big
you're literally buying insurance
against
a cyber attack and that's what a lot of
businesses are doing probably worth it
to help
it's a very good business i'm telling
you right now i think
the insurance industry with cyber
security i think that's going to be one
of the best business next
next 20 years you've got if if you don't
have a mechanism to stop them
say they have your client list in some
capacity right
a major a major corporation say they
have your client list
they're going to abolish your client
list they're going to
disintegrate your files they're going to
do all this stuff
they want to have a million dollars so
you're going to lose your client list
you're going to lose your data you're
going to lose everything that was in
your servers your systems
unless you pay you're going to pay how
do you pay
through the insurance company wow i have
a question for you bernie because
uh you were the nypd commissioner
around 9 11 right during 9 11. so
taking it back to i'm i'm 40 past 42
41. um i remember being this is 25 years
ago i remember being 15 years old
late 90s mid 90s and literally calling
up and asking one of my best friends who
was like a computer geek
uh hey jeremy what's the difference
between the internet and email
uh can you just break that down for me
buddy i literally had no idea
1996 right okay so five years later
we're dealing with 911. you brought up
uh
96 i think i bought remember the
american express had a
had a thing you can buy a computer
online and
people were buying computers and i was
like dude i don't know
why why would i ever need a car why
would i need a computer you know
aol account i'm going to get an aol
account right
who just sold the who just uh they sold
the joining
exactly and they lost the exclamation
point so they're not excited about it
yahoo used to have the exclamation point
ayola is not yahoo yes correct but it
used to be yahoo with an exclamation
point
they took that away meaning they're not
too excited here's my question for you
so we're going back 20 years or so what
were the major concerns
back then pre-9 11 and even post 9 11
versus what they are today we talked
about cyber and this malware
and taking down the grid but so bring us
back to
what the world looked like 20 years ago
when you were running the show
running the show versus what it looks
like today i think back then
um you know we weren't as concerned with
cyber as we are today not not even close
not even close
today is a it's a major could be
a major national security threat back
then
it was the criminal element in the nypd
um we had a big intelligence component
we had been attacked prior
the radical muslim
you know groups we were familiar with
we were concerned with um
and and the organized crime change you
know
years ago up until i guess the 2000s
you know a lot of the organized crime
major organized crime in new york city
was
italian right the mafia
um you know today when the fbi says you
know they've
they've hit the mafia they've you know
they're taking out a
a substantial organized crime mafia
group
the guy's 90 years old he's coming out
of his [ __ ] house in a bathroom
like really dude you know what you know
what i mean it's amazing
so continue
and his walker you know they got him out
to the car
today it's the russians today it's a
chinese
things like that those organized crime
groups
are serious concerns
terrorism a serious concern in new york
city
only because we've been through it we
are i think new york city is still the
primary terrorist
target in the united states um
but cyber is one of the most uh most
important
at pre-911 how big of a concern how high
of a rent of alert was
a terrorist attack like the world trade
center was it well it was still it was
high
and there were things we were always
concerned with keep in mind you know the
mass transit system we have
you know five million people that go
through the mass transit system on a
daily basis in new york city
you know you drop uh you know some
chemical agents in the subway system at
five o'clock
at grand central station you've got a
major
problem so these are always these were
always concerns of ours
you know in the aftermath of the attack
on the morning of september 11th
after the planes hit the buildings we
shut down
the mass transit system we evacuated the
other buildings in new york city
you know that had major height on them
uh worried about
incoming planes worried about you know
the third plane
fourth planes we didn't know how many
planes were out there but we also
shut down the mass transit system got
everybody out of the subway system
because i didn't know if there were more
attacks planned
i didn't know if there was something
going to happen on the ground
you know a coordinated attack like this
you don't know
you don't know what they did you only
know what you're getting at the time
um what did they have planned did they
have coordinated attacks planned on the
ground
you know um shore up the synagogues
shore up the churches the government
buildings
the mass transit these are all things
that we had to worry about at the time
and and you were you were you were with
giuliani right you were escorting
giuliani around because there's a
what's the whole story with you and
mayor giuliani during uh
9 11. well when when the first plane hit
tower one i was actually in my office
giuliani was uptown he was at a
breakfast and
i was in my office and my chief of staff
and one of my security guys came in
banging on the door that
a plane had just hit tower one
and i thought they were a little overly
excited because i
thought that that plane would be a small
cessna or one of these small areas you
did not think it was a terrorist attack
no the morning no i thought you know
what i thought it was i thought it was
one of these small planes that could fly
up and down the hudson river
the helicopter is a small aircraft you
know taking people in and out of lower
manhattan
and uh then all of a sudden i looked up
at i had a tv in my office
above a treadmill in the back of my
office and i could see the damage to the
building
and i walked out to my phone at my desk
i called the mayor
and he said i'm on the way downtown i'll
meet you
at seven world trade that was where the
emergency command center was for the
city
so uh i got dressed because i was
standing there taking a shave when this
happened
i got dressed uh and i was down
to the entrance of vesey street probably
within seven or eight minutes
um got down to the corner uh came down
west broadway went to turn on the vessey
and there were cops there
and a sergeant came up to my vehicle saw
me in the back seat i had my window down
saluted me and said uh boss you can't
get onto the block they're jumping
and i didn't i didn't know what he from
the building yeah
i got out of the vehicle walked to the
corner of vessey
and i could see this debris coming off
the building um and then it's
you know within seconds i realized that
the debris that i saw coming off the
building wasn't really debris it was
people
and they were coming down two or three
at a time
so we backed the vehicles up west
broadway to barclay
waiting for the mayor in about three
minutes before he arrived
the second plane blew through the north
side of the tower so when you
when you see that big orange fireball
blow
blow out the north side of trade center
i was standing under that fireball and
we were looking up and i didn't know
i didn't know at the time what that was
because i didn't see that plane that
plane came in from the southern end of
manhattan
and then i could hear the aviation
pilots uh our pilots the helicopter
pilots
in the nypd yelling that a second
aircraft had just hit tower 2.
so it was at that it was at that moment
that i realized that we were under
attack
um we didn't know anything about dc
didn't know anything about the pentagon
hadn't happened yet
pennsylvania nothing nothing none of
that stuff that was
another half hour behind us the mayor
got there in about three minutes
we looked at the front of the building
the mayor wanted to go down to west
street we walked
literally walked to west street over by
the financial
center looked at the damage to tower one
and two from that side of the street
and then i brought him back to exactly
where we picked him up at barclay and
west broadway
so he could call the white house he
wanted to call the white house who
wanted to call president bush and ask
for
air support and
we were in that we were in that office
with the mayor
and my executive staff some of the
deputy mayors when tower two imploded
and it was it was only about a hundred
yards from us
so basically it imploded on top of us
wow pretty pretty i mean everybody
remembers where they were at with 9 11.
everybody remembers where they were with
9 11. what i want to do is
i want i want us to talk about some of
the numbers came up here about new york
and the crime rate what's going on over
there i want you to kind of give us
uh what a day because i know even right
now your son's a cop
in jersey right and he's been one for a
while and
i want i want people to know what is the
difference between being a cop today
after
the whole defunding police after the
whole campaign of you know
the way cops are being painted right now
if a story comes out that favors cops
being bad
they'll highlight it all over the place
if a story comes out with the cops doing
the right thing
it may get uh shared in a couple places
but they're not going to share it so
it's only the bad part that they're
shown with cops right what is the
difference between being a cop
in the 80s 90s versus being a cop in
2021 2020
i think the biggest difference is the
the public
image of policing has changed and
because of this radical left-wing
movement
um you know what i i think is a a
pretty substantial push for socialism in
the country
you know back in the 80s 90s 70s
police officers male female they were
respected in the community in your
classrooms
your children were taught you know cops
are the good guys
they go out and they do a job that a lot
of people wouldn't do
a lot of people wouldn't have the
courage to do they're underpaid they're
understaffed
and people respected them just like you
respected people in the military
over the last 20 years or so especially
the last
10 over the last 10 years 12 years
that's all changed and there's been this
major push
by the radical left to demonize police
and we have a lot of this going on right
now in especially in major cities and
what's ironic
it's those major cities that have this
push to
victimize the thugs and villainize the
cops
it's those major cities that are run
in a manner um contrary to the way
giuliani ran
new york city and their violent crime
their shootings their their murder rates
are through the roof because there's no
accountability
because they're not enforcing the laws
because they have
district attorneys that are being funded
by these
radical left-wing organizations soros
you know soros funded the guy in philly
the d.a
he funded the the woman in saint louis
there's a bunch of these district
attorneys in cities around the country
that are not prosecuting people to break
the law
and then you have legislators that that
create
laws and governors sign off on them like
in california
you know you could walk into a cvs in
california
and steal 995 dollars worth of
goods and walk out and you cannot be
charged anything under a thousand
dollars
can be charged wait can you say that one
more time say that one more time
so you you can go in and basically steal
up to 999 dollars
worth of material out of out of a store
and nobody's going to charge you with a
crime this is what city what state
this is california in california
california today tell me that is not the
most pathetic thing you've ever heard
it's i can go into a store are you this
is a law in california no it's it's yeah
it's laws
and prosecutors will not prosecute so
what is it anything less than a thousand
anything less than a thousand so that's
so why does
anyone just go into any store and just
say oh i'm taking this pretty much they
are
in in a bunch of stores are closing down
but here's
here's the problems what you have now is
a three-prong
problem you have legislators
and governors that are enacting
legislation
that handcuff the cops that
you know bail reform these bail reform
laws
you can't hold anybody that you're
locking up anymore
um that's number one number two the
prosecutors
they're targeting cops more than than
they're targeting bad guys
and uh and i think the third thing
is handcuffing the cops in general where
you have
like for example in new york city you
have
the mayor of new york city who's
basically during the riots last summer
told the cops take a light touch de
blasio de blasio
take a light touch on crime so you have
all that going on
and then you got this this push by
black lives matter and antifa primarily
black lives matter and groups like that
where they're creating this vision that
there's systemic racism in policing
and that cops primarily target
blacks and and brown people um
you know to go out and shoot them right
you know without cause you know uh
and i sent uh actually said something to
sam i know if you guys got it uh
you got you got that uh yeah they're
gonna bring up something i want to show
you because
these are real numbers okay real numbers
um that are going on right now these are
numbers i'm going to show you for
2020. okay and in doing that
you know if you listen to the mainstream
media if you listen to what's being
reported
you'll you'll hear people say that cops
you know they shoot unarmed blacks far
more than they shoot unarmed whites
okay so i'm going to show you something
at a close to 50 million police suspect
interactions
50 million 50 million
there's 10 million arrests in the
country
last year 2020 2020 20
of interactions 10 million arrests
they fatally shot police fatally shot at
a 10 million arrest
they shot 1021 people okay right
out of that number fatally shot 983 were
male 38 female
457 were white
243 were black 170 latino
151 other but here's the interesting
number
especially given what you hear in the
media
unarmed suspects unarmed 24
white 18 black eight hispanic five other
the percentage the status coming from
where this is coming from
so the the arrest numbers are coming
from the fbi okay
those fatally shot numbers they're
coming from the washington post
which keeps a major washington post
that's right they keep a major database
on
fatality shootings dating back to 2015.
okay washington post is not friends of
the cops
no they're not they're on the left okay
those are the numbers
the chances of you being shot as a black
male today
unarmed based on last year's numbers is
0.00018
really that's systemic
that's systemic racism come on in and
here's the bottom line
cops don't go to communities
based on race they go to communities
based on crime
what they do is they they they take a
map of a city
they put a map of a city on a computer
like this
they pin map where that crime is
happening
the dispatching of the police the police
resources
the funding everything is focused on
where the crime is
there's nothing on there that says what
color you are in the community
religion you are
where you come from whether you're a
citizen or not
nothing it's strictly based on crimes so
when you look at the
when you look at that big crime map this
is where the crime is
that's where the cops are going and
unfortunately you have cities today
like atlanta baltimore minneapolis
chicago new york city
they're all every single one of those
cities are run by a democrat
they're run by a democrat and every
single one of them
are facing the same issues the highest
violent crime
highest murder rates higher shooting
rates
and there's
between the laws between the prosecutors
and handcuffing the cops those numbers
are going to continue
okay do you have questions on that i got
some stats i want to cover
go go i do have some questions if you
have questions go on the questions well
i do and this is
um you know i've seen your interview
that you did with vice which was very
powerful
right right and uh have you seen that
pat no i have not okay
really powerful so you know this is
this is specifically talked about
unarmed shootings right
but you've been actually so i'm almo
this is a question but it's also kind of
singing your praises but also maybe just
kind of
trying to understand the the logic here
you're basically saying that there's not
systemic racism in the police force
especially when it's concerned with
unarmed shootings right right or
violence okay violence
according to your vice interview you
know you were very outspoken that there
definitely needs to be prison reform
right
and uh the steps that are and you were
actually vocal about how blacks were
in the system sort of targeted
judicially unfairly so here's
here's the problem in in this not only
not only am i an advocate under
president trump
um he signed the first step act uh i was
pretty instrumental in getting getting
that
passed i was actually in the oval office
with him when he signed the bill
and that was to basically create
incentives
good time incentives for inmates in
federal prison
so they they would get out sooner
without keeping them locked away forever
and a bunch of other things but to go to
your question
here's my problem with the system you
take areas like um
let's take baltimore for example the dea
goes in
and they do these stings right where
they're going to lock up
really bad guys guys are engaged in
violence guys are bad guys
i have no problem with going after the
bad guys the really bad guys if they're
authentically you know the villains
right
but when you have young kids today 18 19
17 years old they go out there buying
dime bags of cocaine
right and they get caught up in these
conspiracies
with these other bad guys well guess
what
they get charged with the same amount of
weight that the bad guy did
if the guy's doing two kilos a week and
you went out and bought
three dime bags in a week and they saw
you and they witnessed it
and they called you for those three buys
you get you get charged with the two
kilos how's that even possible
well that's like what's the logic in
that like if there's there is no logic
okay there is no logic and that's my
argument so what you do
is you then take that that young kid who
had no prior record
you lock him up and you basically say
look
you're looking at life because that two
kilos that gets you life
you're looking at life take a plea for
10 years
and your defense your your defense
lawyer
most of them are you know provided by
the courts
he says you got to take the deal take
the deal you'll be fine
10 years you're you're not doing life 10
years you're 18 you'll be able to right
you'll be out when you're 26. just take
the deal okay great
you you sign a plea for 10 years
okay you do eight okay
you had no criminal record you had no
criminal background
you're not a bad kid but guess what we
did
we took you and we put you into a system
that's full of monsters right what is
prison
prison is a training ground for thuggery
criminality
you learn how to steal cheat lie
it's like a business school for thugs
it's it's a business school for thugs
and violence right you need to survive
you need to learn how to fight you get
into a verbal altercation
and you know the end of that is usually
somebody getting knifed
pummeled cut um that's the bottom line
that's what we did we took that that 18
year old kid
who had no violence no problems we put
them into the system
and then at 26 we sent them home and
legislators in washington have sat
around
in circle jerks for the past 30 years
they can't figure out why the recidivism
rate isn't dropping
what's this word recidivism revisiting
yeah right gotcha so the recidivism rate
isn't dropping
because these guys have no choice but to
revert to crime they come out after 26
years
and i had kids in prison that i was
teaching classes to
and i would say you know you got to get
your ged
you got to you got to try to get some
college when you get out
and they would look at me and they'd say
commission i'm black
i'm a convicted felon i'm not going to
be able to get a job
that ged is not going to help me and
here's the sad thing
for the most part they're right they're
right they're right well
the question for you because when you
have a felony on your record you're
[ __ ]
no you're [ __ ] yeah and and they know
it
right and they know so it's like all
right what's the point of getting the
ged the high school degree because once
i'm a felon
that's gonna follow me for life any any
job they ask you have you ever been
convicted of a felony
yes [ __ ] that candidate i mean is that
basically what happens that's
exactly what happens nobody nobody gets
it nobody
you know everybody talks a good game in
the in the legislators you know oh we're
you know we want to do this we want to
do this you know what
you know getting that first step act
signed by president trump
it was a major headache if it wasn't for
jared kushner and
in a whole cadre of people around him
that fought like hell with these
legislators
that thing would have never got signed
never and it's still not enough it's far
from enough but obama was doing stuff
too and i know you're not a fan of obama
but i know but i work
i worked with the obama administration
trying to get it done
trying to get it done i i spent i was in
the white house
physically four or five times during the
obama administration
wow trying to get it done trying to get
these guys to work together
and you know listen i am i am uh
these days i think everybody in
you know for the exception of maybe five
people
out of all of congress you know the
senators the congressmen they're all
full of [ __ ]
you know they they tell you one thing
privately
they you know oh it's the right thing to
do you're right you're 100
right you're right you're right you're
right you're right you're right and they
walk out the door
they stand up at a press conference and
they say well we're not sure
we don't know we'll have to look at it
you know there are issues like politics
they have to kind of defend their
position their political party
they not only defend their position but
they're basically
you know some guy didn't sign off on a
bill that this guy
wants well it's it's revenge time so now
i'm gonna not i'm not gonna sign his
[ __ ] because he didn't sign mine
it's pretty ugly let me just some people
are asking right now saying pat fact
check fact check fact check
i'm going to give you some stories here
an instagram post went viral the other
day
right it had 100 i don't know 18 000
likes kai whatever the number was with
uh
you know a post on the days without
police killings in 2021 right usa today
story
if you can pull up that instagram post
so people can't see it the claim on
april 18th
there had only been three days in 2021
but police did not kill someone
okay in a wake of high profile fatal
shootings at the hands of law
enforcement in areas such as columbus
ohio chicago
some users have taken a social media
highlight number of police related
shootings in the first quarter 2021 one
white
viral post presented statistics on the
matter
there have only been three days if you
want to pull it up there have only been
three days in 22 i'm on page seven
there's only been three days in 2021
where police did not kill someone reads
an april 20th
instagram post with over 118 000 likes
while the data presenting the claims is
accurate based on u.s today's research
experts note that there are cl or
certain factors to keep in mind
where they're looking at such data as
state law standards and police
department
policies which govern where police is
allowed to use deadly force
officers legally are given the authority
to use deadly force to defend themselves
or others from an imminent threat
when we dig into this data what we see
most of the time is that the person was
posing some type of deadly threat
some type of deadly threat says justin
nicks an associate professor of
criminology and criminal justice at the
university of nebraska
this continues to go into new york i
don't know if you can find the post or
not uh
kai okay why don't you just put when you
click on it does it go somewhere or no
whether it says instagram post click on
that
there you go that's the dates okay
so 118 000 likes it shows three days
which was
january 14th january 23rd uh
january 16th january 23rd march 3 uh
second the only three days
that somebody didn't die or those three
days i don't say i can't see so good
great if you look at gray it's zero so
january 23rd and march
it could be okay it could be but by the
way if you look at this number and the
data that you gave the data that you
gave
was what it was 1021 which divided by
365 is about three a day
three a day okay so the average is three
day which means you're gonna have some
zeros but you're gonna average around
one two three a day
one to three a day in all of america but
but that's here's where people they have
no [ __ ] common sense
think of the numbers okay 10
million arrests annually
that's that's people 20 20. that's
physically people that are arrested
okay to get to that number you're gonna
have
five to ten times the interactions
you don't arrest everybody you stop
right
so you have five to ten ten interactions
per arrest okay so between
50 million interactions you have 10
million arrests
you have 1021 people fatally shot
okay that's two or three a day in 50
states
and there's 850 000 police officers
that is far from systemic but people
don't they don't get it you're saying
it's a spin job
it's it's a big spin job you know this
is that
you live in a world where it's all about
that it's all about that right right
it's the data king right here yeah no
he's he is the data king
so when you look at stuff like this you
have to look at it realistically
not through the the the scope of some
right wing or
left-wing lunatic the the bottom line is
look at the data you can't hide dead
bodies
you can't you cannot hide dead bodies
you cannot hide i mean it's not tough to
come up with a statistic of
how many times the police has had an
interaction with somebody that's an easy
data to pull nowadays and how many times
has led to an arrest
50 million to 10 million that's 20 by
the way i went online while he's giving
me the numbers i'm doing my own research
so if you're listening to this
you ought to be doing the same thing as
well the washington post article i found
you can easily find the article because
some people are saying
give me the link go online type in the
numbers you'll find it matter of fact
kai why don't you share the article so
they can find as well
i want to continue i want to continue
with this okay because this obviously
got a lot of interaction this got a lot
of people to be talking about it
can you go to change's instagram i want
to know go to change click on that right
there you go to it
so change is sustainable fabrics fair
trade production carbon neutral cloning
so okay so we already know where uh what
uh they stand be critical of right wing
government and israel okay we know where
they stand
so let me read this other article that
has this is a new york post article
about new york data proves it
pandemic is no excuse for new york
city's rising tide of violent crime
earlier this month four new yorkers were
shot dead in four incidents with 24
hours followed by a triple shooting in
times square
this is a 1980s level crime and the city
is getting used to it
with alarming uh alarming alerts uh a
large city
no it's not a large city alacrity
alacrity mayor de bla
bill de blasio answer to this is that
there's not much we can do
our entire lives were turned upside down
a global ban pandemic and a perfect
storm he says
so he hasn't acted with much urgency as
the murder rate rose
47 last year to a total of 468 people
killed and he has risen this year so far
by 17
this is just new york is what we're
talking about the rest of the world is
demonstrating
the obvious murders and other crimes
should be down during a pandemic right
look at the statistics here
so folks if you're listening to this new
york is up the rest of the world is down
in london the murder rate fell 16
during the pandemic in italy it dropped
by 14
in japan it dropped by 10 in france it
dropped by two percent
and even in mexico it dropped by half a
percent so what is wrong with us
not just new york but the country as a
whole with urban murder rates up 30
percent last year one answer is that
compared to europe and japan we have
more guns that's been a crisis for
decades
yet it isn't new what is new in new york
and the rest of the country is that we
have effectively halted all preventative
policing we have also effectively
stopped all incarceration of suspects
and criminals short of murder
so what do you have to say to this
article by new york post what did it say
478 homicides 468 460 last year
47 okay so let me give you a number
in 1993 there were 2
200 murders in new york city
2200 in 1993
okay there was no [ __ ] pandemic
this ain't about a pandemic this is
about
thugs being victimized this is about an
administration
de blasio's administration that has
handcuffed the cops
he took a billion dollars out of their
budget he took 600
plainclothes anti-crime cops off the
streets
when you work in plainclothes and i work
plainclothes as a cop
okay i'm not talking about narcotics if
you're in a plainclothes unit in new
york city
can you explain what a plane closes to
folks who don't know what's playing
close all right let me give you an
example
times square okay where we first met the
first time i ever met you was in times
square
taxis yellow cabs everybody sees a
yellow cab in times square
well let me tell you an old trick i'll
give you some old trivia
if you see a cab and the number
on the cab in the middle letter was an r
and the last two numbers were the same
right on that cab
the three people that's riding in that
cab usually there'll be a driver and two
people in the back seat
those are cops okay they're in plain
clothes
they're in yellow cabs or they're in
plain clothes they're in unmarked cars
when you say playing clothes they're
dressed like you they're dressed like
normal yeah usually it's jeans sneakers
a vest
you know a jacket whatever the case may
be they they blend in they look like
anybody else
may have a beard not beard whatever
bottom line here's their job their whole
function in life is to look for guns
and respond to what we call hot jobs
robbery in progress
shooting in progress shots fired
so you know somebody getting stabbed
whatever the case may be
their job is violence that's all their
job is
bill de blasio took 600 of them all of
them all the plainclothes units in new
york city
took them off the street 600 of them why
would he do something like that
he put him back in uniform why what's
the matter he said they were a threat to
the communities
in what way i don't know i i don't
what's the speculation though even the
speculation what is the speculation
my speculation is he's a [ __ ] that's my
speculation
very deep he's got to have some
justification for i don't know
he's got to look at stats i don't care
i don't know i'm asking well because
because it's like it's almost like it's
not fair people should know you're a cop
you shouldn't be hiding like you're not
a cop maybe that's what it is like
transparency
right that's the whole point of being
undercover here's
here's the bottom line he takes a
billion dollars out of the budget
he takes 600 cops out of the streets
plainclothes unit cops their whole
function in life is to look for guns
takes them out and basically opens up
rikers lets people off rikers
institutes these laws with the city
council and the governor
where they're not going all the things
that pat just talked about right
you know they're not locking them up
they're letting them out they're not
holding them for bail
all that stuff so here's the bottom line
would you say the numbers
last year 660 460 468 468.
2200 in 1993
okay between 1993
i left office in 2002 january 2002
we dropped that homicide number from
i walked out of office i think my number
was 671.
under mayor bloomberg we got it down to
371.
370. something like that
we had i had a 65 percent reduction in
violent crime
a 70 reduction in homicide
and an 80 percent reduction in homicide
in the black communities where the
violence was the highest so what did you
do during that time that they can be
doing today
what were some of the strategies and
tactics you guys used everything they're
not doing today which is what
basically um i'd have plain clothes cops
out there if i was
if i was the police commissioner today
right
i would go to the mayor and say i want
the billion dollars back
i want two new classes of 2000 each
in class i want 4 000 more cops than you
have
i had 55 000 people to work for me in
the nypd
41 000 of those who were uniform today
i think they're around 36 000 why
you have a bigger population in new york
city today than you did
in 20 years ago right why do they have
less cops working today
that's that's crazy and keep this in
mind
here's here's here's what people in in
all those cities i mentioned earlier
whether it's atlanta baltimore these are
gorgeous
some of these are gorgeous cities right
nobody wants to live visit work
or go to a school in a place where
they're not safe
nobody wants to move into a neighborhood
where they got to put their kids to bed
in bathtubs
to protect them from gun violence that's
the bottom line
for every percentage point giuliani and
i and the other commissioners for every
percentage point we reduced
violence and homicide i could show you
increases
in economic development real estate
value
and tourism every percentage wow
it's up it's it is the bottom line you
know
a lot of the advocates in in these
left-wing lunatics will get jump
on the on this totem pole saying this is
all socio-economic
we need better jobs we need better
schools
we need whatever we need they'll talk
all this [ __ ] right
bottom line is you're not getting none
of that
you're not getting none you're not
getting better jobs you're not getting
better schools
as long as you have the highest violence
and crime
and the highest murder rate in your city
you're not getting none of that other
stuff why would somebody build a small
business over there
what risk am i going to take that's
exactly right
who's going to put a business there
who's going to create jobs
you think you think apple is going to
put a flagship
store on the on you know the south side
of chicago
no they're not the bottom line is
you have to fix the violence in the
murder ring
so let me continue because okay so
bernard to to be fair with the audience
you would consider yourself uh a
republican you would say you're a
republican yourself okay so you're a
republican
new york post is a a
center-right newspaper a post is new
york time has left new york post is
right let's just kind of so i just read
to you stats
from new york post so somebody may say
and and usa today is
left but new york post usa today
usa today center left i think wall
street journal today
is center center right yeah so new york
post
is right now next one npr what is npr
far certainly left far left right so
this next story i'm reading to you is
from npr
massive one-year rise and homicide rates
collided
with the pandemic in 2020 this is an npr
story and they have a data if you want
to pull up that link right there so they
can see it open for visual data guy
uh pull it up so they can see it at the
end of 2020 chicago police reported more
than 750 murders
okay this is 2020 during the pandemic a
jump of more than
50 percent compared to 2019 people were
out and about in 2019 people stayed home
in 2020
how the hell is murders up 50 in chicago
from 2020
to 2019. by mid-december l.a
saw a rise of 30 over the previous year
with 330
322 homicides there were 437 homicides
in new york city
by december 20th nearly 40 percent
higher than previous year
new new orleans-based uh based data
consultant
jeff asher studied crime rates in more
than 50 cities and says the crime spikes
aren't just happening in big cities
with the numbers of homicide spiking in
many places asher expects the final
statistic
for 2020 to tell a star a startling grim
story
we're going to see historically the
largest one-year rise
in murder that we've ever seen
asher says it's been more than half a
century since the number since the
country saw a year to your
murder rate that jumped nearly 13
this is npr this isn't new york post
this is a wall street journal this is
npr and here's your answer
the answer is this has nothing to do
with the pandemic
in my opinion this has to do with every
one of those cities where
i where i was talking about chicago
included
you know chicago you're not allowed to
chase a bad guy
you know that right you know the mayor
said the mayor of chicago
um that was the hillary muriel bowser
yeah says
you can't you have to get permission
from a supervisor
to run we're not talking [ __ ] car
chases
we're talking about running after
someone
you're not allowed to chase them unless
you get a supervisor's permission
okay that's the kind of [ __ ] that is
killing the police how does that even
mean
what is your job well i don't know guys
committing a crime can i get an approval
let me get a approval from this type of
management
you know 10 minutes later the guys are
already coming you can't chase them in a
car you can't chase them on foot
you can't confront them you there's no
stop
question and frisk nobody wants that
anymore
basically they don't want you to do
anything that's the problem
that's the problem this is not about a
pandemic
this is about a change in the way
we deal with the criminal element well
here's what bloomberg comes out and
bloomberg we know is a left uh left-wing
uh uh
side but they're pretty reasonable i
think when it comes down to economics
their center i like to get bloomberg's
facts but when it comes down to it
bloomberg ran as a democrat for office
and he's got a media empire this is the
story new york city's violent crimes is
up
so is the city's police budget would you
consider bloomberg a decent mayor for
new york city
he was he was okay fair enough so
protests calling to defund the police
have become a familiar side of new york
city but this year mayor de blasio gets
his way
one of america's most progressive cities
will actually send more
more dollars to the nypd than it did a
year ago this is a story from yesterday
the spy promises to
strip a billion dollars from city's law
enforcement budget
which gained national attention in the
wake of george floyd's murder last year
the blast you slashed less than a half
less than half that as part of a broader
round of pandemic cuts and a spending sl
plan for fiscal 2020 to announce this
month keeps police head
uh head count and operations intact
leaving
any major shake-ups of the force up to
whoever succeeds the term limit
mayor in january but now with shootings
in march
up 77 over last year let me say that one
more time
shootings in march of 2021 up 77 percent
from last year and an influx of more
than 4 billion dollars
in federal stimulus funds available for
mental health at risk youth and other
social programs the notion of taking
police officers off the streets
has become less politically palatable
for the mayor and the dozens or so
candidates vying to replace them next in
new york is the largest police
department in the u.s
and has amongst the highest number of
officers per capita there were 436
officers per 100 000 in the city in 2019
compared
to 249 in la or 233 in houston according
to the fbi so
even de blasio is sitting there saying
maybe i screwed up what do you think
of course he screwed up and they all
know it all you had to do is look at
minneapolis minneapolis is the first one
that started this whole defunding mess
right
they wanted to defund it they wanted to
diminish they wanted to annihilate the
police department
they defunded to an extent they also
wanted to bring in social services
instead
of cops and all this all this nonsense
right
well last month or two months ago they
had to basically come out and say okay
yeah we screwed up we gotta we gotta
refund
what we defunded we need 200
immediate cops back on the street we
need abc the bottom line is
the funding isn't going to work i don't
know what that what the mentality was
behind the funding
but it's not going to work your cr
everything i predicted
when minneapolis started the funding
everything i've said
everything i've i've predicted has come
true
you defund you diminish their budget
you take away staffing you take away
resources
and here's here's the absurd thing you
take away their training
right so for the past 30 years
we've tried to train cops to do
everything under the sun
you want de-escalation you want verbal
judo
you want less lethal force you want to
give them
non-lethal force tools every single
thing that we've tried to give them to
make their job
better make them less confrontational
make it work
easier in communities well now we're
going to defund it we're going to take
all that [ __ ] back
really it makes it's absolutely
it makes no sense you know what i think
about like a soros imagine you're a cop
working for the guy what are you
thinking
what are you thinking you're thinking
they're morons no but but
i'm actually like literally
yes you're thinking they're morons but
what are you thinking are you sitting
there saying man am i gonna do a bang-up
job for this guy like
imagine that relationship like you know
this guy cannot stand you this guy wants
to get rid of you but he also knows he
needs you
but at the same time with the media he's
kind of have to we're talking about the
mayor right now
no no no i'm talking about yeah i'm
talking about no
hold on yeah hold on think about this
though
the city council members they have cops
they have drivers
the city officials the mayor he has a
protective detail that's probably
ranges somewhere around 25 people
those cops that work for him despise him
right i know many of them i know many of
them
they despise him they can't stand him
and they can't stand them because he's
anti-cop he's anti-pd
he hates them he despises them how do
they work together on a daily basis but
they have a job to do
they have a job to do just imagine like
you're working for a guy that hates you
hates what you stand for but on a
personal level and
not interacting and i think you have the
city council in new york city
they they basically brutalize the nypd
on a daily basis
brutalize them on a daily basis how do
you interact with them
you have a job to do you go out and you
do your job you it doesn't make any
difference
who's on the other side i respect the
guys that are doing it you know for me
when i joined the military i knew
nothing about like when i went to the
military it wasn't because my dad was a
general or a
sergeant major or i'm gonna go follow my
dad's footsteps i went in the military
because i couldn't wait to get out of la
and i just
got in and i went into the army and i
realized what some of these guys had to
do and the sacrifices they made
my appreciation for you know soldiers
went to a whole different level
a lot on what they had to sacrifice cops
man who who the hell wants to be a cop
today who wakes up in the morning wanted
to be a cop today and today
your son is a cop in jersey right in
newark
what what's he telling you what's he
saying like does he tell you what's
changed in the last 12 months
on how much crazier it is how they treat
him do they treat him with respect is he
seeing some
well i i gotta be honest his uh his
supervisors in newark
his boss actually who just retired
anthony ambrose was the police director
in newark until about a month ago
and i have to i have to admit in the
last
i think two years anthony ambrose
brought down
newark's violent crime the lowest it's
been in 50 years 40 years
tremendous job but how did he do it
he did it exactly the way new york city
dropped crime over the last
20 years right prior to de blasio same
stuff
phenomenal boss uh my my son you know
has a lot of respect for him what he did
uh
during his time newark's a rough place
it's one of the most uh violent crime
ridden cities in the in the
in the state of new jersey um he happens
to be on their swat team
he's been on the team he's a team leader
has been on their team for about 10
years
he's he's it's crazy he's 35 36 years
old and he's been on the job 16.
looks just like you by the way no you
know yeah good looking guy a lot of
[ __ ] good looking guy you know
yeah a lot of a lot of people he became
a cop when he was 20 years old
he became a company he's 19. wow went on
the job when he was 19
he started in patterson which was was
another rough place
you know it's funny he's from paterson
new jersey is that where cory booker's
from
no cory booker is from newark newark all
right there it is yeah i was
i was born in newark and i was raised in
patterson
and uh yeah he went on to 19
in patterson and then he got laid off um
and you know the father that i am you
know i'm thinking
i'll get him a great job and ridgewood
new jersey you know gorgeous
town small town you know make good money
i called him up to my house and i had
him sit down and i said listen dude
where do you want to go i says i i got
some great recommendations
he goes no i i know where i'm going i
said where are you going
he says i'm going to newark i said what
are you on [ __ ] drugs like
new york like what's the matter with you
you're going to newark
he goes i said think it like
think of the money like these other cops
make
you know a third more than you do he
said i'd laugh and he says yeah
i'm talking to the guy that was the
warden of the passaic county jail
and left and went bankrupt to join the
nypd
i said okay all right yeah granted but
think of the violence
think of the violence and this is this
is his response to me
he says that when your wife has geese
in a swimming pool out back she calls
the cops
he goes i'm not chasing geese around the
[ __ ] swindler
he goes i can't do it he said
i gotta he says i can't do it he says i
just gotta you know i look
he's got a need for speed i like what i
do i like the guy
genetics genetics i would have been the
geese guy i'm not gonna lie
to you attention
we got 16 geese right out here riding
with brendan
you know today did you see this attack
did you see the kid and the teacher
having a you know he's not a kid 19 year
old
a 19 year old young adult who had the
exchange with his teacher where the
teacher
was uh saying bad things about the cop
this guy was defending it did you see
that exchange yes
did you see it you haven't seen it can
you put that video on i want to show
this it's two minutes i want you to
watch it
so the teacher and another student are
not for the cops this one student stands
up and says i think cops have a very
hard job
okay pat can he there's something else
though that you should look at
just to show your viewers the mentality
of the far left
in that case that was a professor
professor that was a professor in a
college
okay that that's number one but number
two
there's a car stop there's a car stop
that went viral about a week ago and in
that car stop
there is a teacher um basically
stopped yeah she's stopped by an la
sheriff you're a mexican you'll never be
white you'll never be
oh really can we bring up the
the military interaction with the
company but i want to show this
if you've never seen this i want to get
your reaction on this i know he's seen
it so
so kai do me a favor do the playback
speed increase that to
1.5 and let's on the ball today ladies
and gentlemen
and your speech a few times um so what
is your like what is your main concern
since i mean honestly the whole reason
police is i mean
who is she the teacher she's a teacher
because the whole reason we have
police departments in the first place
where did it stem from what's our
history going back to what
we were talking about what is it still
from it stems from
people in the south wanting to capture
runaway slaves
maybe they shouldn't be heroes maybe
they don't belong on a kid's show
uh so i disagree with the what jeremy
said about it because uh i think cops
are heroes and they have to have a
difficult job but we have to have a lot
of
life oh i'm not i mean i'd say a good
majority of them you have
you have bad people in every business
and every year
wait wait wait police officers have
committed the josh's crimes and i've
gotten away with it and have never been
convicted of any of it
and i say for a person who has family
members who are police officers this is
a teacher
professor um and this is what i believe
this is my opinion and this is you know
not popular to say but
uh i do support our police and we have
bad people people that do bad things
should be brought to justice i agree
with that
but i think that uh say i'm saying again
well i agree with you on that point if
they should right so what is your bottom
line point you're saying police officers
should be revered
very angry on tv shows with children i
think they are heroes in a sense because
they come to your need and they come and
help you and
they have uh problems just like every
other business but we should fix that
but
they're they're heroes looking at it as
a business because they're actually
supposed to protect
and serve the people do you protect us
we're in trouble when someone has a
knife or a gun
why would you call the police i don't
trust them my license more danger call
and their presence professor who would
you call i wouldn't call anybody
see she's a [ __ ] nut this you know
how do you do
it
and i know that it's not popular for me
to say that to you guys and then people
in here but that's what i
believe about the police thank you i
appreciate it thank you you've got to
respect this guy though man just how old
is that kid
probably 19 years old kyle if you want
to pause it probably 19 years old taking
a stand and saying that and the
teacher's saying i wouldn't call the
cops what do you mean you're not going
to call the cops
when you call the cops it's not a
republican or democrat i'll
fight it myself can i ask you a couple
of rapid fire questions
i'm sure we got to move on rapid fire
bing bing bing bing bing give a grade to
mayor giuliani mayor bloomberg and mayor
bill de blasio
giuliani at 10. uh mayor bloomberg i'd
say
10 uh mayor de blasio
ii uh why is he not a one
he's a [ __ ] zero i mean
really you know i don't know or whatever
giuliani
fall from grace that's a question mark
no
you think he's still doing all right
he's doing fine i talk to him on a daily
basis he's doing okay
okay uh a couple rapid fire questions uh
magic wand magic wand
uh if you could change the image of the
police how would you do it
i wouldn't i changed the image of the
communities
i'd start teaching young kids today that
you can't
violate the law that you can't attack
cops that you can't resist the rest
you can't interfere with another arrest
i start
teaching kids in the communities things
that
maybe they don't know maybe they do
but the bottom line is many of the
interactions that go negative in
policing
they start with a suspect that did
something wrong
or is suspected of doing something wrong
and then they resist
and if they didn't resist we wouldn't
have that
the overall confrontation that occurred
are cops asked to do too much
yeah uh honestly uh they're asked to do
a lot
i wouldn't say too much uh they do the
best they can under the circumstances
okay last question
you were the commissioner of new york
city nypd
aka gotham you got batman you got robin
right behind you they were running the
streets of gotham
what are your thoughts on what's going
on behind you um
you know it's it's a crazy time crazy
world no literally behind you right
there oh
no these i i like this guy but i like
this guy better
i like this guy better you're like
batman better than the joker yeah
so let's let's talk about let's talk
about uh what's going on with israel and
palace sir
i think a lot of people are asking us to
talk about that topic and i think we
need to
especially uh adam you haven't been
there multiple times and you've
been um your family from israel yes so
let's go to page 11. here we go
page 11. republican okay is it page 11
or is it page 12 12
uh senior hamas commander killed as
israel strikes gaza palestine's fire
rockets this is a reuters story the war
the worst violence since 2014 between
israel and palestinians
showed no sign of letting up wins that's
continued israeli attacks and hamas
rocketed the rocket fires prompted the
u.s and the united nations to warn the
conflicted mushroom
into full-scale war israeli bomb
uh israel's bombing campaign in gaza has
now killed 53 people including 14
children and injured more than 300
people
according to the gaza-based palestinian
health ministry israel's
shin bed security service said the
brigade commander of gaza city was among
senior members of islamic
islamist islamist militant group hamas
who had been killed
militants in gaza have been have fired
more than a thousand rockets into israel
killing six israeli civilians
injuring more than 200 others the
israeli military said wednesday around
130 rockets hit tel aviv last night
forcing israel's main international
airport ben
gurion to close many of the rockets were
intercepted by israel's iron dome which
by the way what a system they have with
the iron dome air defense system
but several struck tel aviv setting the
bus of blaze and killing one israeli
woman thousands of israel spent the
night in
bomb shelters in gaza which has few bomb
shelters and no air defense systems
several buildings and apartments were
damaged by israeli airstrikes
one of those strikes brought a
multi-story tower block tumbling down
the israeli defense forces said the
building
was stronghold of hamas military
intelligence and weapon
research uh i will go to you first adam
tell us what are your thoughts on this
well obviously it's tragic what's going
on but go a little deeper tell us
yeah of course this is this is a sad
situation but unfortunately it's nothing
new
all right i mean this is the first
flare-up in since what 2014
but um i think we've all seen what's
going on
with israel and palestine and it stemmed
from the war 1948 the six day war when
israel became a state
and egypt and jordan and palestinians
everyone attacked them and in six days
this little country called israel
defended themselves
and they did it in the war of uh 67 and
and then just the yom kippur war and
somehow this little magical country
israel exists in the sea of
um
muslim you know countries all around
them so no first and foremost israel
does have a right to defend himself let
me just state state that number two
um this is not a black and white issue
so me being jewish
like obviously people can say oh you're
biased and that's obviously you're gonna
you know support israel but i will say
that
there are parts of israel that i don't
necessarily agree with so
for instance the palestinian the israeli
settlements
that they're trying to
essentially take over from these
palestinians fam
families who have been there forever
these settlers are definitely aggressive
and it's hard not to sympathize with
somebody who's been living in the same
house
for decades and now settlers come in and
say well the government says it's my
house now
and uh thank you for being here what the
hell would you do if you lived in that
house for 30 40 50 years
and you're palestinian you think you're
giving your house up without a fight
are you kidding me so that's not a micro
issue from a macro perspective
here's how i kind of look at it um it
you know palestin you know
you know they say like don't bring a
knife to a gunfight well palestinians
are bringing rocks
to a literal rocket fight so you know i
use this analogy with ricky the other
day and he was that he's like what the
hell's going on there you know ricky's a
big dude
and it'd be like if dylan because dylan
was there kept coming up to ricky was a
big guy and hitting him
and punching him and kicking him yeah
he's only seven years old
but at some point you're gonna hit back
so
you know palestinians are throwing rocks
you know
they're literally launching rockets uh
and israel is gonna only take it to a
certain extent when they said listen you
do that again and we're gonna
excuse my language kick your [ __ ] ass
and that's essentially that's
essentially what netanyahu said yes
exactly yeah so at some point if you
know and i'm not comparing palestinians
to a seven-year-old but
in terms of strength they're no
comparison
to what the palestinian or the plo or
hamas has
compared to what israel has but at some
point
look it's such a tough situation that i
do actually sympathize with the
palestinians and i've been to israel i'm
jewish i have family that lives in
israel
i have a cousin of mine who moved from
detroit to join the idf
so yes i have some bias here but i do
understand the plight of the
palestinians if you're constantly
a second-class citizen in where you live
how do you expect to react
so this goes down to another macro
perspective the one state or the
two-state solution so john kerry
who was um was john kerry's secretary of
secretary of state
okay so he said the jewish people cannot
if you do a one-state solution you're
familiar with the one-state two-stage
solution if you do a one-state solution
because there's more arabs living in
israel than jews
he said if you do a one-state solution
israel can no longer be jewish and or
democratic it cannot be both so a
two-state solution both have the right
to exist the problem is
and i'll turn it over to bernie after
this the problem is there's people in
hamas
who are a terrorist organization that
are running palestine the palestinian
terrorists
the united states has labeled the people
running the palestinian territory
a terrorist organization hamas they do
not believe that israel has a right to
exist
just like how in iran um
the the people running the azerbaijan
army there's a bunch of them
they do not believe that israel has the
right to exist so
on a fundamental basis if you do not
believe a country
if you're not exactly azerbaijan doesn't
believe armenia has a right to exist
that's what you're saying
if you saying that you don't believe a
country has a right to exist and you're
doing everything
to usurp their who's to blame who's to
blame here listen i i understand that
you know trevor nor
you know trevor noah i don't know when
you heard what he said you know he was
like well
if when i was younger and i was a older
brother
and i would beat up my younger siblings
my mom would say
but my mom they hit me first and mom
would say but that's your brother
why are you hitting him all this other
so why are you hitting them the
difference here is this is not your
brother
like this is not like this is a very
difference you know what
they're not hitting them either the
hamas i think you said
fired over a thousand rockets a thousand
rockets if it wasn't for the iron dome
they would have killed hundreds hundreds
of israelis
thousands potentially no no potentially
thousands potentially
yeah thousands of rockets they they shot
right
the bottom line is we're not talking
about a fist fight we're not talking
about somebody getting hit
we're talking about deadly physical
force right
if you infuse that force if you you go
out
it doesn't matter who you are it doesn't
matter who you are it doesn't matter
what the argument
is you know there's ways to deal with
the argument
you know there's a hundred ways to deal
with the argument and i think the un for
once
should probably do a better job
they've never done a good job but that
they should be doing more to
to rectify the internal issues but the
bottom line is
you can't shoot rockets into israel
deadly rockets and they anticipate
they're not going to shoot back
yeah just think about like netanyahu's
press conference well look
to the israeli people i'd like to speak
to you i know we got
bombed and i know we had 100 rockets
that were shot our way
in a span of a five minutes or ten
minutes whatever the number was
they're smaller army than us we
shouldn't retaliate god talked about
forgiveness
you should forgive them he would not be
like no no what i'm saying to you is
forget it's netanyahu yeah
say biden gives that speech we're
america yes 9 11 happened but we
shouldn't retaliate
no no this country is not say you're
rush
say you're any country if a prime
minister says this what do you say
you're you're the voter you're fired
that's what i'm saying you're a mother
with three kids and the only thing a
mother thinks about with their kids as
the s word what is
it security and safety right you want me
to sit there and say well
netanyahu this is why this israeli
they're they're they're too aggressive
they're too this they're too that
what is the alternative to look the
other way when you're looking at what
is is that going to cause hamas and
palestine to stop no they're not they're
going to continue doing what they're
doing so
my my my challenge with this is
you when you get into topics like this
you'll get people from both sides
you know you cannot believe you said
this came this is not about me taking
israel's side or palestine side
if you're gonna do something like this
you best do something like this knowing
you can beat israel
you can't if you're gonna start a fight
you better believe you can finish the
fight what is the point of starting a
fight if you know
it's not going to favor you like what
it's emotion like
something that i've had to learn here
being a part of valuetainment and
everything is
try to be more logical not emotional can
you imagine the emotion
of somebody they killed my grandson
they took my house it's you're running
on pure emotion you think there's logic
in behind their actions they're mad
they're angry they're upset they're
still
they're still angry that someone killed
their cousin from 40 years ago and
they're harboring that anger what do you
expect them to do no i'm not defending
i'm not justifying their
armenian and armenia went up against uh
azerbaijan azerbaijan's got five times
the amount of budget you got with
backing of erdogan turkey the largest
military in the middle east while putin
doesn't have the backing of armenia
putin does business with turkey you
think putin's going to take the side of
armenia back him up who's going to
defend palestine and
hamas to say hey you're going to go up
against israel we'll back you up and go
defend a war against israel
the most ridiculous air force in the
world won the best military technology
rejection
most insane you know secret intelligence
you want to go up against somebody like
the idea of
well i don't know to bernie's point and
you bring up an amazing point here the
fact that israel
10 years ago they
they invented this iron dome which
essentially is a missile defense
mechanism that with 90 plus percent
accuracy you can shoot down
rockets that are coming over its border
imagine if they didn't have that
that's what i'm saying imagine if they
didn't have that thousands of missiles
landed in the country yeah people are
protesting israel they're using the
forest they're using force
imagine a thousand people died would
israel have the justification to do what
they want no
there's of course but but here's a
complete different story here
i'm going to go a complete different
angle you know what that dome did to me
when i saw it
what did it do to you when you saw that
what like forget about when you saw like
you know how you see it in the videos
like boom you're like yeah
what did you think about when you saw
that you i've seen that for years but
i get that when you see it what do you
think about it the ridiculous technology
okay
you think about safety you think about
wow that's pretty sick you think about
the direction we're going
where security and safety from doing
wars
is gone meaning if you want to bomb a
place those days the technology is
getting so advanced that countries are
going to be able to put a
bio you know this kind of a dome over a
person it's not a literal dome i know
of course yeah you know what people
think about that think of this
yeah think of this you know and i i i
have a lot of friends in the special
operations community right
think of this today in washington dc
somebody somebody could pick up a phone
and call somebody in dc and say
we have a guy this is his grid
coordinates
he could be on the other side of the
[ __ ] universe
some completely like somewhere hidden
somewhere wherever within
30 minutes we the united states
has an ability to drop a bomb on that
guy's head
no matter where he is in the world think
about that
no matter where he is you know how do
you feel hearing that
that the fact that we have these
capabilities yeah i mean it's ridiculous
it makes does it make you feel safe does
it make me feel safe that we could do
something like that
i mean it doesn't make me feel unsafe
okay no but but what i'm saying to you
is the fact that folks in israel
yeah they they ought to be grateful
for the technology advancement that that
country's invested in
to provide that kind of security because
here's how small is israel
israel is not a big country this is the
size of like delaware yeah israel is so
tiny it's ridiculous and by the way
palestine's even smaller like
when you think about how small it's and
it's not it's
it's not also just wartime capability
right
when the fbi had a hard time getting
into the iphones
right who'd they go to they go to they
go to the israelis well there's an
amazing book called startup
nation uh that i read i don't know 10
years ago and it talked about how this
little it's like the little engine that
could
how this little country was able to
manifest itself into this ridiculous
technologically advanced country
uh and i'll say one thing because i i'm
sure we'll move on to the next topic but
we were texting ironically yesterday or
dm'ing yesterday
on the plane you remember this yeah
and you and we were talking about uh
israel and tel aviv
and you go i guess we're not opening up
a valuetainment office in tel aviv
anytime soon haha and i go and i've been
to tel aviv
i actually said the opposite yeah you
said i guess we i guess
i guess we are because of how safe it is
okay i thought you were being sarcastic
no no i was saying the opposite i was
saying you would feel sleepy now he's
gonna check
to make sure no no no no no no it sounds
like a safe place to move out
in headquarters i thought you were being
sarcastic
if you got one of those that you're
protected but here's what i'll say about
tel aviv
i'm from miami i'm from i'm from miami
beach it's like miami beach bro
like it's like you go to the beaches
you're having a great time you go to the
discotheques you're dancing you're doing
the uh
you're having fun you're living a life
that you would not think you're living
in
in the middle east it's awesome uh yeah
but adam you know what
that's all over the middle east you know
when we're watching you're watching
video of syria right you're watching
the bombs and the you know the the
knocking out uh sites and doing all this
other stuff
you go online you go on facebook and
you'll see people in syria
they're having weddings they're having
parties they're going out to restaurants
and you're looking at this thinking
where the [ __ ] is that guy because
i just saw this morning in aleppo
whatever yeah
i just saw this morning where they
annihilated an entire city
and this guy's getting married you know
that's all over the middle east
why because it's the way they've learned
to live
they had to live like this you know i
worked i worked for the king of jordan
for five years
and jordan's a pretty secure country
jordan has
been great for the last it's been great
40 years um but i was also there
in november of 2005 when they
bombed the three hotels right in all
over
this country everybody was saying oh my
god
it's it's losing it it's not going to be
secure anymore there's no security in
jordan
and yet i was in jordan i don't know 70
times over five years
um it's phenomenal it was a phenomenal
country
it's the way they've learned to live
it's it's the way the israelis
have learned to live they have to you
know you go into a mall
in tel aviv you're going to be checked
for weapons
you're going to be checked for a vest
that's the way every
every uh israeli citizen bless you
from the day they turn 18 has to join
the idea of israeli defense force
and you're learning everyone has guns
and the guns in the country
everyone has them ak-47s whatever it is
and it's a very safe place you feel very
secure so
as a jew as a jew you know
you go there and it's it's not what you
like for instance the jewish people in
america they they you kind of get this
like uh everyone feels safe no
not at all exactly you feel like every
jew is like a mud green pig from
the family guy and he i'm at the
pharmacy like that's what's uh
but they're they're freaking bad asses
it's ridiculous
uh most uh most aggressive zoom in you
never joined that military
i did meet some nice girls though you
did i didn't i can see that
how about we talk a little economy i
want to get two stories in before we
wrap up we got nine minutes
okay cnbc story inflation speeds up in
april as consumer prices leap
4.2 percent fastest since 2008.
now when you read this story
this is the highest raise rate of
inflation over the past year jump from
four point two to two point from uh two
four point two from two point six
percent of prior month
highest since 2008 senior federal
reserve officials who are supposed to
protect the us
from high inflation insisting increases
temporary
they contend inflation will subside by
next year over the pandemic phase most
people go back to work and global
economy is
largely recovered now here's some
interesting statistic based on this okay
on what
increased energy prices overall jumped
25 from a year earlier 49.6
increase for gasoline 37.3 for
fuel oil then on top of that
this is the this is the random weird
statistic used car
and truck prices which are seen as a key
inflation indicator
surged 21 no what the hell is
used car prices going up 21 just in
april alone
it increased by that little you know
lemon you're going to buy for 2 200
bucks
it's officially 2 500 bucks okay that
the 10
000 truck you were gonna buy last year
this you're gonna have to pay twelve
thousand two hundred dollars for it
uh a used car so you know what's gonna
happen with this are the rates gonna go
up is you know are they trying to kind
of keep people calm
they don't wanna scare anybody lumber
prices alone have risen 124 percent in
2021 once again
lumber prices alone have risen 124
percent they're saying it's from though
what are they saying they're just saying
it's just temporary it's not because you
know
based on what and copper often has seen
this proxy for economic activity has
jumped nearly 36
percent by the way house is here you
know what kind of houses people are
buying that
they're moving here from new york or
other places they're wanting to buy
homes that have already been fully built
the tear downs
they're not there's there's not too many
teardown companies it's ridiculous
because of lumber being ridiculous
prices
right exactly building costs going and
also in new york you get a you get a
shoe box for a million bucks down here
you're living the good life yeah
you are living a pretty good life at a
million bucks so but new yorkers stay in
new york
inflation no no right away tough it out
i don't
you know here's the problem with that
with new yorkers people from jersey
people from the northeast
you want to go to florida because you
feel safer
you want to go to florida because the
you know the the
the economy is better yeah okay go to
florida
but don't bring your politics with you
keep your politics up there
don't come down that's hard to do and
try to vote the same way think the same
way
because thinking the same way isn't what
changed florida
your politics in new york city is far
different than what's going on in
florida
the politics in new york city is why
you're leaving new york city that's
exactly right right so so you so
either keep your ass up there or
come to florida but you better stop
voting differently because otherwise
you're going to turn florida into new
york
bernie why are all these guys from new
york why are they coming to florida why
aren't they going to alabama why aren't
they going to the lovely state of
mississippi
you know southern state south carolina
living in a [ __ ] country with a bunch
of sheep
you know i mean you weren't how are you
edison you were miserable hanging out
with your two cats more than any other
kid i'm miserable with the cats man
don't bring the cats too little cats of
yours man
yeah so bernie i have a question for you
before we move on because you said you
got a lot of love down here you were
walking the streets of boca bae barney
who are the people that are giving you
love hey barn good to see you and where
are the people are hey you [ __ ]
bernie get the hell out of it oh yeah
what's the difference you get
you get those for far and few between
but when you get them
yeah you know i'll tell you a quick
funny story i was crossing madison
avenue my
little girl who's now 18. she was about
two years old this is after 9 11
after giuliani and i leave office i'm
crossing madison avenue up around
nello's around 61st street
nice area i'm crossing the street and
there's a guy walking across he's like
your age
he's walking across the street facing me
and he goes
carrick right you carrick i see yes sir
and at the top of his lungs he goes
you're a
dick you're a [ __ ] dick he starts
healing in the middle of the street and
everybody's like whoa
what happened what's who's this guy so
you get
and it was bill de blasio you probably
is kid
you get you get those kind of people
that are complete lunatics
but for the most part you know
everybody's nice but down here
when i'm in palm beach or boca or fort
lauderdale
i'm telling you i think it's like a
sixth borough this city because
everybody's like hey commissioner how
are you doing hey come here bernie
what's up they're all done the mecca i
mean especially
boca's like the mecca of new york and
jersey i think they just
lifted up like somewhere up there and
brought it down yeah and it's going to
be more just because of what's going on
with new york this is not going to slow
down
i can't tell you the numbers because
last night
you weren't at the house you were over
there i'm in the process of buying a
house right now okay we made a few
offers but this one's gone far
i get a call from my realtor yesterday
saying this guy is willing to
pay you xyz dollars i'll say it once the
house closes then i'll reveal the
information so people can know about it
there my realtor is telling me let this
guy buy the house from you i said i
haven't even bought the house yet yes
but legally this is your house because
you're in contract he wants to buy the
contract from you
and he wants to pay you this much i said
how am i so my wife says
babe it's a big number but please say no
she don't want to go through the process
because she's pregnant we got
we got what five weeks left june 21st we
got six weeks left for that baby
fourth baby to come up so life is very
busy right now but the point is
guys are coming in here they're they're
saying look what is what is the asking
price
i'll give you two million more i'll give
you three just let me get this place
because it's a it's the bidding war
today in florida
is insane okay okay so that being said
what do you think in a year from now a
year and a half from now you think the
bubble's going to burst
not in states like florida texas
tennessee nevada it's not
not those states really texas is going
to take listen
texas is going to keep blowing up
florida's going to keep blowing up
tennessee's going to keep blowing up
nevada is going to keep blowing up there
are certain states they're not going to
why tennessee
taxes lowest taxes in all of america
lowest taxes in all of america
i'm actually going to tennessee i lived
there for two years it's one of the best
places to raise a family
one of the best places to raise a family
and it's not like country bumpkin
national no they got all sports i mean
nashville especially you got you can go
live in a nice place brentwood national
brentwood nashville which got 10 50
million dollar 20 million dollar homes
you can go get a quarter million dollar
home and be right outside the city
20 can you imagine a 20 million home in
nashville it's a palace i was going to
say what's interesting
it's a palace literally it's a palace
but it's a beautiful place beautiful
place to raise a fan
if it was if we wanted the water because
our kids loved the water
we would have lived in nashville
tennessee i just want i want like 20
acres in the woods somewhere
with a long driveway and a house just
big enough for me
upstate new york no no stop upstairs
stop
alabama i want a [ __ ] register
hey come commission how you doing good
to see you down here come here
let's let's finish oh man there's bernie
let's finish it up with liz cheney page
12 if you want to go to it adam so liz
cheney okay
this has been a mess in the republican
party right now representative liz
cheney says she will do
everything she can to make sure that
trump never again
gets anywhere near the oval office the
business insider story
she's uh from wyoming on wednesday said
she's determined to prevent former
president donald trump from returning to
the white house i will do everything i
can
to ensure the former president never
gets in anywhere near the oval office we
have seen the danger that he continues
to provoke with his language
we have seen his lack of commitment and
dedication to the constitution cheney
told reporters on capitol hill
the comments came after cheney was
ousted as chair of the house republican
conference in a voice vote on wednesday
morning gop members voted to remove
cheney from the top leadership
post over repeated criticism of the
former president opposition to his lies
about the 2020 presidential election
she was also one of the top one of the
10 house republicans who voted to
impeach trump over his role
in the capital insurrection on january 6
thoughts my thought is she's a liar
and and i'm glad she's gone and i say
that from personal experience
i ran the investigative side of the
president's rebuttal on the election
i saw the 3 000 affidavits from people
that witnessed voter fraud election
fraud in six different states
she was never briefed she was never
interviewed
she never called us she never questioned
us
she hasn't seen one bit of evidence out
of the outrageous evidence of voter and
election fraud
yet make statements like that and for
that she shouldn't be in congress
i don't i don't know liz cheney
personally like you don't know or not
not you know personally but um and i've
said this before
people are like oh the democratic party
is falling apart the socialists are
taking over but
from my opinion they'll at least
coalesce during an election and come
together
in my opinion the the party that is
being fractured
is republicans you have what does it say
a hundred republicans
including former governors and lawmakers
are threatening to form a third party
these are people that were lifelong
republicans
the bushes of the world the chinese of
the world the george wills of the world
we saw
you know how the um the lincoln project
took over the collapse though
it didn't end well let's just correct
but they did
they did bring down trump they did from
the democrats used them to bring him
down and then afterwards they crash and
burn because they're no longer needed
they're the useful idiots some call him
well they knew what they were doing
some of them called them the useful
idiots they were useful when needed the
moment everything was accomplished now
it's no longer fair enough but the point
is that i'm trying to make is if there
is some
the bigger division is definitely in the
republican party than it is the
democratic party
right now we'll see what happens i don't
disagree with you i'm actually on you on
your side with this because this
is so you have to realize if if you if
you
knew how powerful dick cheney was
he he literally ran the show no no the
guy is a strategy
he's one of the scariest guys on
politics the guy was a strategist the
guy was a
he was feared by his peers he's so
powerful he could shoot his buddy in the
face and not pay a price
the you can say that because that's
actually a factual statement yeah
so so can you imagine his daughter she's
got those genes
yeah the the genetics of a fighter the
genetics of defending and cheney was
whose vp
channel was bushes okay in the bushes
and trumps how's the relationship did it
go to dinner to get admired bushes and
trump's not good so
not so good so because they're closer
with obama's at this point of course so
the point is you have to know where the
loyalty lies
right where the loyalty lies it's like
cindy mccain now here's a question megan
mccann here's a question for you here's
a crazy question for you here's a crazy
question for you it's getting crazy uh
sam am i above my appointment 1102.
okay so here's a question crazy question
for you here's a crazy question for you
republican party say there's a split we
have a third party i know we have like a
few other third parties whatever
independent libertarian green all that
but i'm talking about like a legitimate
25 party right which party is more like
ronald reagan
the liz cheney bush you know
party the the the the what do you call
it conservative republicans the lincoln
project do you think
they're more like reagan or do you think
trump's mega party is more like reagan
who's more like more like and wagon like
reaganomics like reagan the way he ran
america
who's more like reagan trump's you think
so 100 what do you think
i'm taking the opposition so let me if
you listen to your typical if you're
listening
if you're listening to this yeah thumbs
up if you think
the the the trump is more like reagan
versus the chinese the bushes of the
world
are like reagan thumbs up it's more
trump like raikkonen thumbs down if no
it's bush cheney or more like reagan i
actually want to hear your thoughts when
you're saying this so tell me why you
say ray
trump's camp mega is more like reagan
because he believes in much of the same
stuff reagan did
you know smaller government you know the
the the bush
con republican party is all about the
swamp
it's all about the swamp it's all the
the connections the the
long time connections of washington dc
and look i i got to be honest i followed
this stuff for years
i never got involved as much as i did in
the aftermath
of the election and there were people on
the bush side of the house the
republican side of the house
basically saying leave leave the
leave the election alone don't talk
about it don't go public
don't cooperate with them don't talk to
the president's legal team
why why not what are you hiding
or what are you trying to prevent from
happening the bottom line is
there was overwhelming evidence of voter
and election fraud
i saw it i collected the affidavits we
interviewed
hundreds of people i got it but
why wouldn't you want that to come out
why is it why is it
not okay to talk about it they censored
the president they
censored the president they've censored
anybody that goes on social media and
tries to talk about it
for the people that were there that saw
what i saw
this is outrageous and i don't give a
[ __ ] if it's republican and democrat
i don't care the bottom line is every
vote should count
and every vote should be ill legal a
legal vote
when you have 350 000
ballots that are cast between 1 a.m
and 5 a.m in pittsburgh and there's no
republican observers
okay that's illegal it's illegal it's a
[ __ ] crime
when you have 150 000 cast in
philadelphia
between 1 and 5 a.m that's a crime
why hasn't it been investigated how can
liz chaney stand up and say
it's all a lie what do you say to those
who say bernard
this has already been addressed it went
to court even
georgia you know the governor came out
and he didn't do anything even you know
you can go to
here's here's what you say about the
court issue the court issue
and and i'll i'll finish with this one
statement the court issues in in almost
every case there was no state they
didn't find that the
petitioner had standing or they said
it's a state issue
and you know what they're right here's
the bottom line
for the people that were there the
democrats stole the election
they infused ballots they [ __ ] with
the machines they had dead people voting
in the thousands
they stole the election but that is not
why donald trump
is not the president today donald trump
is not the president today
because the state legislators in the six
swing states
certified false votes and they knew it
and they knew it they certified their
election numbers
in those states just to get it over why
because they're a part of that bush
entourage that bush party
they hated trump they didn't like what
he stood for and they
are the reason he's not in the white
house today so you're saying it's the
actual republicans who are running 100
so not even the democrats you're saying
is it the democrats or the republicans
the democrats stole the election but if
the republicans did their job if the
state legislators did their job
and did not certify those votes until
there was
a real investigation you have arizona
right now
right now today they're still in court
messing with the audit in arizona you
have the same thing going on in michigan
in antrim county
where they found the turnover of trump
votes to biden
they found them in the machines that
stuff is still going on
the certifications should have never
been done let me ask you
and in the the great words of uh big
lebowski
it's kind of like your opinion man how
accurate do you think no no
meaning like are you 1000 confidence is
exactly what happened or it's like look
i kind of think this is what happens
i am a thousand percent confident you
know why because i have the affidavits
i have the legal affidavits they're
sworn under the penalty of perjury
there's thousands of them thousands what
do you [ __ ] ignore these people
that were there what are you blaming who
do you blame for all this because it
sounds like you're blaming republicans
i am blaming republicans oh my god i am
but by the way say there's a third party
let's break those two apart
say there's a third party okay so so now
when
no if there's a third party by a
landslide who wins
democrats not by a landslide not even
close or
or does because because it seems like
the fear is so high that they're
thinking trump's going to run 20 24.
do you think he is 20 24 i don't know
what's your best 80
chance 60 percent 50 80 80 very high
yeah 80 runs okay listen if so many
people are doing everything in their
power to prevent it from happening
they're thinking very high likelihood
he's going to be running and they're
scared that's all i can say to you
and i don't know no no no bro if you're
saying stuff like this this is only
stemmed from fear what if what if this
takes place
petrified yeah there you don't think
this is coming from conviction
and moral authority i do think it is but
the only reason you're putting so much
energy into it is because you also
believe odds are this guy's going to run
we cannot have this guy run because if
he runs what's he going to do what's he
going to expose
what's he going to show what's he going
to revert back to what's going to be
taking place what's going to be the next
swamp we're going to lose our deals i
don't know
but all i know is i wish we had another
hour today but we don't we went nine
minutes over caroline is standing over
here telling me pat you got a call to
get on
uh bernard man it's been great having
you on bro i got to tell you this was
phenomenal
thanks dude yeah we're gonna have a good
lunch right afterwards we'll uh go
grab a bite and we'll have you back on
hopefully here soon again and on behalf
of the six
six borough welcome uh we love it we'd
love to have you again
yeah see you in the streets yeah man
this was great
this was great thank you okay folks if
you're listening to this we are doing
this again i believe tuesday i'm
officially back in town we'll be doing
this again back in two days if you
enjoyed today's podcast
smash that subscribe button it is a
different channel
we will see you next tuesday have a
wonderful weekend everybody take care
bye bye
you